that's Marduk so the story of Marla I'll
just give it to you very briefly time at
a naps who are locked in embrace at the
beginning of time
goddess of salt water God of freshwater
together
chaos an order right they give rise
masculine and feminine they give rise to
the world of the elder gods and those
are to me their primordial motivational
forces there's something like that and
their rage and their lust and their love
and all these things that possess us
that are there forever and they're out
in the world acting and they carelessly
slay apps ooh their father and they're
making a rocket and then they collapse
ooh and then timeout gets wind of that
and that's a timeout right there by the
way she's kind of a rough-looking
creature and she's the mother of all
things and so she's not very happy about
this they know these her children have
destroyed structure itself plus they're
noisy and careless and so she thinks all
right just like Noah just like the God
that brings the flood to Noah exactly
the same idea time Matt comes back and
says yeah okay enough is enough I'm
gonna take you out and she makes this
battalion of monsters and puts the worst
monster there is at the head of the
battalion his name is king you he's like
a precursor to the idea of Satan and she
lets the gods know hey I'm coming for
you and so they're not very happy about
this because their gods but like yeah
she's chaos itself right she gave birth
to everything this is no joke and so
they send one God out after another to
confront her and they all come back with
their tails between their legs there's
no hope and then one day there's a new
god that emerges and that's Marduk and
the guards know as soon as he pops up
they know he's something new remember
and this is happening while the
Mesopotamians are assembling themselves
into one of the world's first great
civilizations so all the gods of all
those tribes are coming together to
organize themselves into a hierarchy to
figure out what proposition rules
everything and so Marduk is elected by
all the gods and he says look I'll go
out there and I'll take on time at but
here's the rule from here on you follow
me I determine destiny I'm the top god
I'm the thing at the top of the higher
and all the other gods say hey look no
problem you get rid of chaos we do
exactly what you say
now Marduk he has eyes all the way
around his head and he speaks magic
words those are his primary attributes
and so he takes a net and he goes out to
confront time out and and he he he
encloses her in a net which i think is
so cool because it's an encapsulation
right it's a conceptual encapsulation he
encloses chaos itself in a conceptual
structure he puts it in the net and then
he cuts her into pieces and he makes the
world and then then he creates human
beings to inhabit that world and to
serve the gods and he creates human
beings out of the blood of king of the
worst of the demons and that took me
it's a calling to Jung who's a student
of mine helped me figure that out I
thought he's that's pretty damn
pessimistic it's like you know what
exactly it sounds like a fall metaphor
it's like the idea of original sin but
but our joint conclusion with regards to
that was that human beings are the only
creatures in creation that can truly
deceive right we have the capacity for
evil just like it says in the Adam and
Eve story we can actually do that and
that's why we're made out of the blood
of king of the king of the demons the we
are that thing that can deceive that can
twist the structure of reality well so
Marduk now the the massive team has had
an emperor right and the emperor was the
avatar of Marduk that's what made him
Emperor he was only at Emperor if he was
going to be Marduk he had to be a good
Marduk which Mantia do confront time at
chaos and cut her up and make order out
of her pieces and what the Mesopotamian
is used to do at the New Year's
celebration they'd go outside their
walled city and that's explore territory
versus unexplored territory they go
outside their walled city into chaos and
they bring all the statues that
represented the gods and they'd act this
out because they're trying to figure
something out right they're trying to
figure out what this means they're
acting it out and then they take their
Emperor and the priest would make him
kneel and they'd take all his king all
his king uniform off his Emperor uniform
off and make him kneel and humiliate him
and nail him with a glove and say okay
how were you not a good mardik this year
right and then he'd recount all the ways
that he was inadequate in confronting
chaos and then they do the celebration
and Marduk would win and and the king
would go sleep with a royal prostitute
and the reason for that was it's the
same idea as st. George pulling the
Virgin from the dragon it's exactly the
same idea that if you caught if you
encounter the reptilian chaos you can
extract something out of it with which
if you unite you produce creative order
that's what they were acting out and
that was the basis for the Mesopotamian
idea of sovereignty it's so smart it's
so unbelievably smart and you know the
Mesopotamians had a massive influence on
the civilizations that then had a
massive influence on assets one of the
stories of how the notion of sovereignty
itself came to be it's the evolution of
the idea of God that's one way of
thinking about it but even more
importantly it's the evolution of the
idea of the redemptive human being right
and that's taken - it's one of its
conclusions while in the story of Buddha
but also in the story of Christ the idea
of the perfect individual and the notion
is well that's the word that speaks
truth into chaos at the beginning of
time to generate habitable order that is
good that's the story and so with that
let's see oh sure I'll just show you
these pictures because they're so
interesting once you know what they mean
they're so cool that's a symbol of
infinity let's Hercules and the Hydra
what's life like you cut off one hand
what happens seven more girl right what
do you do run hold well no that's not
what you do this is what you do you
fight it